bueno créanme que no es fácil
enfrentarse así ante un mar de gente
imagínense entonces lo que debe ser
sufrir bullying o bullying esas
agresiones físicas o verbales que suelen
ocurrir en las escuelas por eso también
se conocen como acoso escolar
uno de los problemas más discutidos y
graves de los últimos tiempos los
problemas sociales sin embargo hace
cinco o diez años creo que pocos o
ninguno de nosotros han escuchado esta
palabrita de bullying aunque también
suele decirse que esto no es nada nuevo
no que es algo que siempre ocurrió y de
hecho más allá de la edad que nosotros
tengamos no todos tenemos alguna
experiencia con este tipo de situaciones
o ya sea porque la vivimos en carne
propia o porque contribuimos a ejercerla
contra nuestros propios compañeritos
cuentan nuestros pobres compañeritos de
entonces en la infancia o porque
simplemente la presencia más no antes se
llamaba tomar de punto alguien para
burlarse
ahora se dice bullying bueno pero yo
creo que esto que pasa ahora y que
nosotros llamamos bullying en realidad
es algo nuevo no tiene semejanzas con lo
que pasaba antes pero no es exactamente
lo mismo y esto por varios motivos
primero antes no teníamos una palabra
para nombrarla para nombrar el fenómeno
o por lo menos no era esta palabra
bullying
y era noticia no se lo discutía en los
medios no se intentaba promulgar leyes
para prohibirlo o para penalizarlo claro
que podía ser motivo de sufrimiento para
mucha gente y de hecho lo era pero se
pensaba que era algo más o menos normal
capas una consecuencia indeseada un
efecto lateral colateral indeseado de la
convivencia escolar pero no tan grave no
algunos incluso podrían pensar que eso
contribuía a la educación de los chicos
pero hay algo importante y es que en esa
misma época o sea hasta no hace poco
otros dramas escolares se consideraban
mucho más serios que esas peleas sin
importancia que ocurrían en los recreos
en los pasillos me refiero a las
amonestaciones las expulsiones e incluso
las malas notas tanto los chicos como
los maestros los padres y la sociedad en
general pensaban que eso era mucho más
importante que lo que ahora llamamos
bullying
aunque ahora es al revés tiende a ser al
revés
las malas notas y las reprimendas
disciplinarias parece que son cada vez
más graves menos graves y este es nuevo
fenómeno del bullying ocupa un papel
cada vez más central entonces hay un
movimiento simultáneo y complementario
que sucede al mismo tiempo no por un
lado estos los motivos más tradicionales
de humillación escolar que son los
castigos aplicados por una autoridad
como un docente o un directivo a los
alumnos hicieron algo considerado
incorrecto algo prohibido por los
reglamentos o algo considerado que no se
debe hacer como portarse mal o no
estudiar por un lado eso pierde peso y
por otro lado ganan prioridad nuevos
motivos de humillación escolar
esos estos castigos que los mismos
alumnos se aplican entre sí por los más
diversos motivos pero casi siempre por
algo relacionado con el aspecto físico o
con la personalidad de la víctima
bueno si esto de hecho está sucediendo
la pregunta sería por qué no porque esta
transformación en nuestros valores y yo
creo que se trata de un gran cambio
histórico no es un gran cambio histórico
que sobre cuál vale la pena pensar
porque pensamos que por un lado
en esos motivos de humillación escolar
esos conflictos escolares más
tradicionales amonestaciones expulsiones
malas notas lo que opera allí es la
culpa culpa por haber hecho algo mal
algo malo la culpa es una emoción
interna privada se refiere a un
conflicto moral a un drama de cada uno
consigo mismo por haber hecho algo que
no solamente los reglamentos dicen que
está prohibido que no debería hacerse
porque es incorrecto sino que todos
piensan que eso está mal
incluso yo estoy yo me siento culpable
porque hice algo malo
ahora en el caso del bullying no es la
culpa lo que está en juego no sino otro
tipo de emoción la vergüenza
que no es exactamente lo mismo es
bastante distinta la vergüenza es una
emoción pública no se refiere a un drama
privado de cada uno por sí lo mismo por
haber hecho algo mal o algo malo en el
caso de la vergüenza el problema no soy
yo sino los otros los demás la mirada de
los demás que me juzga de un modo
incorrecto y justo a veces cruel más
allá de que yo tenga la culpa o no de
haber hecho algo malo en general no
tengo culpa de nada son los otros que
ejercen sobre mí esta mirada cruel dra
entonces es una transformación hoy yo
creo que esta transformación del
equilibrio no pasa a ser más importante
la vergüenza que la culpa y yo creo que
esto está es una clave para entender por
qué están cambiando nuestras prioridades
aunque me parece que la mirada ajena la
mirada del otro que obviamente siempre
fue importante
últimamente ganó un peso desmesurado
desmedido tal vez
sobre todo al momento de juzgar quién es
cada uno y cuánto vale
y esto no siempre fue así por eso digo
que es un gran cambio histórico y claro
que es un cambio muy complejo que no es
de ahora que viene gestándose hace
décadas y que está como terminando de
consumarse ahora está cristalizando
ahora no y me parece que uno de los
ingredientes más importantes de esta
transformación
es el abandono de la idea de
interioridad qué es eso bueno fue una
idea muy importante una creencia
fundamental durante los 200 años que nos
precedieron siglo 1920
la convicción de que existía la vida
interior no algo esencial pero invisible
a los ojos que se creía que definía a
cada uno de una forma mucho más profunda
y verdadera que las vanas apariencias
esas apariencias no sólo se consideraban
vanas sino también falsas frívolas como
algo menor no algo sin importancia
comparado con toda la contundencia de
esa verdad o belleza interior
bueno yo creo que todo esto son valores
y creencias que todavía permanecen entre
nosotros pero que los estamos
abandonando entonces ya está
transformándose y estamos abandonando
esas creencias
por ejemplo en el caso de las
apariencias me parece bastante claro que
ya no son tan vanas no pensemos en todo
el fenómeno de culto al cuerpo que se
desarrolló en las últimas décadas la
importancia de la imagen personal del
aspecto físico el tema de los gimnasios
los tratamientos estéticos todo eso
también importa mucho si carece de más
énfasis a lo que se ve y se pierde esa
noción de que lo más importante de cada
uno es algo que no se ve pero que no son
las tripas lo que está dentro de cada
uno pero que no son las tripas sino algo
inmaterial como el alma o el espíritu
parece que cada vez creemos menos en eso
y cada vez más en lo que los demás
pueden ver lo que mostramos lo que
hacemos y en función de estas
transformaciones los otros nos juzgan a
partir de lo que ven y menos a partir de
esa noción de que hay algo adentro de
interioridad éter ya medio victoriana
medio anticuada que sería más verdadera
de los actos y de las apariencias junto
con esto no aparecen una serie de
indicios de transformaciones y uno de
ellos sería la autopromoción o las
tácticas o técnicas de autopromoción que
hoy están por todas partes y que hasta
hace poco se considerarían algo de mal
gusto pero empecemos con un ejemplo
la conquista la obsesión por conquistar
la mayor cantidad de seguidores o de me
gusta
esto también para probar que uno es
alguien que existe y que tiene valor y
que merece ser admirado por todo el
fenómeno de las redes sociales podría
ser visto también como una prueba de
esta transformación el éxito de las
redes sociales de internet así como un
conjunto una infinidad de síntomas y
fenómenos contemporáneos que van desde
los tatuajes hasta las cirugías
plásticas pasando por los reality shows
y por el bullying no creo que pensando
en este contexto más amplio no sorprende
que hoy el bullying se haya transformado
en algo tan serio y tan grave cuando las
amonestaciones y las malas notas son
cada vez menos graves no porque parece
que la culpa perdió buena parte de su
eficacia moralizadora o sea la culpa ya
no es tan eficaz como la vergüenza para
producir efectos en nuestras vidas
y esto claro que es muy complicado
porque exige un gerenciamiento un
gerenciamiento una administración de dos
vertientes que parecen contradictorias
por un lado tenemos que exponernos no
tenemos que mostrarnos los demás tienen
que ver lo que somos como somos y lo que
hacemos entonces tenemos que cultivar y
divulgar nuestra imagen pero por otro
lado está siempre el riesgo de que esa
mirada ajena no nos devuelva admiración
sino rechazo burla ignorancia también
que nos ignoren entonces nos hemos
vuelto más vulnerables a la mirada ajena
por ese mismo motivo pensemos también en
la complicación que es el ciberbulling
cuando estas burlas o deformaciones se
diseminan por las redes en youtube
facebook etcétera y entonces lo que
antes solía ser privado no limitarse al
grupito de conocidos o protegidos por
las paredes de la escuela o de la casa
de repente se expone ante millones de
personas no todos lo saben
entonces la vergüenza se hace terrible
mucho más grave y no tenemos donde
refugiar nos han y dentro de uno mismo
ni en la intimidad ni siquiera soñando
con el que aparece a una isla desierta
que cada vez existe menos o sea no
existe más por lo menos no sin wifi no
que ese es el tema entonces pareciera
que esta idea de que el infierno son los
otros se ha vuelto más verdadera ahora
no es la era de la conexión permanente y
de los perfiles siempre visibles en
miles de pantallas y con esta
dependencia que desarrollamos con
respecto al botón me gusta ese clic
mágico que esperamos que todos nos
concedan ante cualquier self y o lo que
sea que apostamos con respecto a
nosotros mismos
bueno si todo esto está sucediendo de
hecho este cambio histórico con estas
consecuencias y efectos la pregunta
sería qué hacemos
también esto es mejor o peor que antes
es bueno o malo cómo lo solucionamos y
bueno la mala noticia es que solución yo
no tengo pero creo que tengo algunas
pistas lean me parece que tanto la culpa
como la vergüenza son mecanismos de
control social no y el hecho de que la
culpa esté perdiendo buena parte de su
vigor ahora y que la vergüenza se esté
magnificando eso no es bueno ni malo en
sí pero es algo que debemos tener en
cuenta o sea es un dato porque si
seguimos que exigía que las cosas
cambiaron de hecho no entonces si
seguimos pensando que lo que pasa ahora
es lo mismo que pasaba antes y lo
tratamos de solucionar como si fuera lo
mismo probablemente no vamos a llegar
muy lejos bueno sea eso lo que quería
contar gracias
[Aplausos]